but i'm fairly optimistic i think that
no matter who wins in the culture war
this is the end of the american empire
it's the the end of this global american
you know mission military bases overseas
will probably start shrinking and the
reason i think that is
the right side whatever that really
means i don't know because it's not it's
not about conservative values
necessarily but it is more about
anti-war it's about freedom it's about
personal responsibility i think if that
succeeds like trump trump supporters
civil libertarianism you've got no
willpower towards foreign war zero none
of these people want it if the
establishment ends up winning if the
left i mean you've still got the
progressive flank coming in and they're
just chaotic and destructive so if the
personal responsibility individualist
faction does succeed america is going to
come back to just working for america
and then the end result the left should
be cheering about well
real quick the progressive activists
should be celebrating that
trump supporters hate war
instead they're combating against them
which says to me they're just chaotic
and destructive so if if the democrats
are the establishment unit party is not
long for this political world i was
going to say that i think isolationism
we had that before world war one i think
and uh part of why world war one broke
out is because the u.s you know looking
back maybe wasn't involved not really is
it not the reason why but
uh you know the military industrial
complex basically was in 1946 i think
the liberal economic order got created
basically to get put american military
bases all over the world british
american french military bases and then
defend make sure that another world war
iii never breaks out another world war
never breaks out um
and i also agree that american
imperialism is on a decline i don't know
if that means that there's not going to
be any military bases america is going
to isolate and then a world war is going
to break out i mean that's that cannot
happen that is to all these military
authoritarians they do not want that to
happen you well you've got the um the
joe biden special interests that are
basically selling us out to china
so
if they gain power then the u.s just
crumbles i guess they want to sell off
all of our assets and resources to china
and extract the value from this country
and then we're left holding an empty bag
and then you have the trump side which
says we want to defend our borders bring
industry and jobs back to the united
states and then there's just no there's
not going to be any power will or or
force of will towards international
conflict from the united states the very
least do they consider iraq part of our
borders
what the right no like joe biden i know
it's a question you can't answer and you
don't know but you know it probably does
here's here's what we got going on the
reason one of the reasons they really
hate donald trump is because their
long-standing plan with europe natural
gas oil pipelines and all that was was
disrupted to such an absurd degree boy
were they spinning they wanted to build
the pipeline i've talked about this but
they want to build the pipeline the
cutter turkey pipeline through syria
through turkey into europe to offset the
gazprom you know uh gas monopoly as soon
as trump got in they knew that plan was
done everything they had been working on
was going to be shut down because donald
trump didn't want to be involved in
these foreign wars he didn't want to be
involved in syria he didn't want to be
involved in afghanistan and that meant
we would the united states would not be
able to win this international conflict
in the region
so they did everything in their power to
shut them down further donald trump
here's what i really think i think
donald trump genuinely was like i don't
know why we have any of this stuff and
the bureaucratic state is probably like
listen we have a plan you need to do
this and he's like i don't care he's
like america america i don't know why
you're doing this and he ignores them
and he won't listen
and then stumbling bumbling donald trump
and i know he's not really but i mean in
this one capacity
he stumbles upon a video of joe biden
demanding a quid pro quo with ukraine
and trump gets on the phone he's like
what's that all about and the
bureaucratic state goes no
like that's our plan we have a company
we've a proxy company we've set up in
ukraine the vice president son is on the
board we got a former cia director we
are we are working ukraine to get gas
into europe and trump just blurts it out
and then that's why they did everything
in their power to stop trump it wasn't
about fascism or racism it was that
trump was just he wasn't supposed to win
he was not a part of their stupid plans
and he was dismantling them and for four
years he really set them back now joe
biden is left with the the neo-liberal
establishment neocon uniparty plan just
in shambles and i don't think they can
recover from it to be honest i would i
would push back a little bit uh so he
had some populistic policies that do
deserve to be commended and and
respected no matter what side of the
political aisle you're on but he did
continue the the war in yemen fighting
alongside al qaeda fighting alongside
the saudi coalition creating one of the
worst humanitarian crisis in the world
he did he did give ukraine lethal
weapons he did send a crap ton of drone
strikes to the point and extent where he
stopped even listing them and even being
transparent about them and then he also
bombed syria because his daughter came
to him and said she saw a scary video
online according to donald trump's own
son so with that happening he brought us
very close to warwick russia that fits
that
i don't think we disagree the yemen
afghanistan stuff is what trump knows he
knows 911 he knows that so when they
come to him and say this goes oh okay
i'll do that i'm not saying what he was
doing was good i'm saying he was
dismantling their plan because he didn't
understand or care about their you know
circuitous plan towards
gas
you know interdependency and when it
came to bombing syria yeah you're right
it was his daughter the the bureaucratic
state
trump hated the head of the fbi hated
the cia he didn't like any of these
people they had smeared and lied about
him so he was ignoring them outright but
when it came to his his daughter and his
son-in-law he was like sure i'll do what
you guys say and so they couldn't
control him and i'm not saying that
means trump was doing good things it
just means their real reason for
opposing him is that
you know i'll put it this way
it is said and and tell me if you guys
agree that the
deep state is called the bureaucrat the
administrative state
they have plans and those plans extend
beyond the terms of the sitting
president so when the new president
comes in they say here's the operation
we're currently working on and typically
the president goes okay you got it obama
would do it right
bush would do it and then trump gets in
and he goes no i'm not going to do it
you can't tell me what to do i've got
plans and then all of a sudden they're
angry and freaking out because trump
isn't playing ball 100 there you go yeah
there was an aspect where he was a bull
in a china shop and he said well we're
just going to take the oil in syria i'm
going to leave the military there and
there's also military individuals that
were lying to him about the exact
numbers of u.s troops inside of syria
which is also mind-boggling boggling
when you think about it in that kind of
perspective but i i think he should
always be judged on his actions uh in
each direction uh but i agree but i
think a lot of people weren't expecting
him to be in there and i think he
capitulated some he fought some but uh i
think that's up for a lot of people's
own personal interpretation way too much
yeah way too much capitulation and i'm
sure you guys have covered this in a
different conversation but uh
my my theory without any evidence is
that he took a dive on snowden because
they made him hmm
how do you explain that and assange too
yeah assange and ross albrecht yep that
he couldn't do it i i kind of feel like
trump thought he was gonna he was gonna
get a second term and so he was you know
i'll hold back a little bit
because i want another term and then
when it started looking bad for him he
said i can't go crazy because i'm gonna
try again and he thinks he's gonna get
it in 2024. and then
i'll tell you this man
if donald trump
takes the white house in 2024
he takes the election and then in 2025
you know come january 20th or whatever
there is another trump administration
he will emerge from that white house
with glowing red eyes and ener energy
emitting from his body as he raises his
finger and he says arrest them all and
he just goes after every single one of
these people who who wronged him or
sliding him who slighted him who smeared
who lied because he's on he's going to
be unrestrained he's just going to be
i'm done playing this
i'm willing to bet he'd fire fouchy
right away i don't know
it sounds like political persecution if
a president gets in and starts arresting
his enemies
i mean people who broke the law
yeah lots of them a lot of them are
breaking the law right there's a lot of
documents they should be arrested all
the executives it's not illegal when the
president does it
trump
trope trump also just a couple days ago
said it's hard to criticize biden now
because biden congratulated him on his
promotion of the vaccine oh my god so
there's also that as well and then
donald trump also doubled down and
made veiled attacks against ron desantis
the governor of florida for not publicly
talking about his booster shot allegedly
that he took according to trump who's
attacking him now um
it was only a matter of time until the
two people butted heads
i'm not saying trump will be right to do
it i'm not saying trump is correct in
every action he's taken i'm saying trump
will get an office and be like this is
my one chance i'm not gonna play around
i've learned i've from the mistakes i've
made and and he's just gonna say i want
the documents released release him now
and he's gonna he's gonna so he's gonna
walk with these people he's gonna say
i'm gonna follow you to the to the
archives and i'm gonna watch you
publicly release these documents right
now under my orders as president because
when you would do all this stuff last
time they'd be like you got it and then
they wouldn't do it and then trump would
forget about it
he is going to go off
the rails he's just going to be like i'm
not playing games anymore he strikes me
like a really bright hot fire that's
burning off of like not a lot of fuel
like uh paper and it's really really
intense but if the wind blows it just
goes out and you're like where was he
when we needed him where was he when
assange was is rotting away in prison
where was he when when his daughter came
crying to bomb a country so he did it
like we need strength and and
you know consistency i i don't want this
bombastic loud i hear you man a clown
show anymore i i hear you on that i mean
i i i've often said i'd meet all these
people who would say i voted for trump
because i liked his policies but man i
wish the guy would shut up but i will
also add
i think there's going to be a lot of
people in 2023 a lot of people have
suffered under joe biden the democrats
in the past year the lockdowns have been
miserable
kids are are upset children have
committed suicide i know a guy whose kid
took his life and it's a horrifying
story because he got locked down and
they didn't see it coming
these people
many of them are just going to want
revenge and are you going to get revenge
with ron desantis i'm sorry the answer
is no ron desantis is younger he's
calmer he's collected he's got a lot of
things right a lot of people like him
but donald trump would be like
unleashing a bowl but this time the ball
is on fire that's a good point uh this
claiming
this kind of anger and redemption
because i was just going to bring up
desantis again because i think desantis
is going to give trump a run for his
money i think a lot of people like
desantis a lot more than they like trump
i think there's a lot of broken promises
with trump i think there's also a lot of
clear corruption a lot of promotion of
big pharma when on the other hand you
have desantis that has essentially
stopped the narrative in its tracks when
it was donald trump that said it's only
going to be two weeks to slow the spread
it was donald trump that instituted warp
speed it was donald trump that you know
said here's here fauci control the
country do whatever you want when
desantis did completely the utter
opposite of that and i think when it
comes to that revenge that aspect is
going to be hindered by the fact that
donald trump caused a lot of the pain
that the american people are suffering
with that the democrats continued uh by
continuing his policies while desantis
was one of the only people standing in
the way of it and saying no i'm not
going to implement your mandates i'm not
going to implement your lockdowns your
restrictions your bull crap on my people
because i believe in personal freedom
and personal liberty and because he made
that stand i do believe he's going to
win out against donald trump in the
larger public opinion luke just wants us
to move to florida that's why i love
florida so i am biased here uh from my
perspective and desantis isn't perfect
there's also some things you could
criticize him on but by and large you
see florida leading the way against the
lockdowns the mandates texas was
following very closely what florida was
doing but florida was the first one that
initiated a lot of these major moves
that absolutely broke this coveted
narrative that actually broke a lot of
this nonsense and stopped it in its
tracks and that's why i do believe
desantis and trump are fighting already
it's going to be a big fight it's going
to be a fight that's going to be very
entertaining but at the end of the day i
think desantis absolutely has this one
in the bag yeah trump has a lot of
baggage when it comes to lockdowns and
it when it comes to vaccine mandates i i
think you know he's he is as you
mentioned he's the guy that platformed
fouchy
and if you go back and and look at what
was going on at the time he really got
sort of led around
by all of these these healthcare
bureaucrats that absolutely wanted to
impose this radical new experiment on
the american people
and with combine that with the fact that
that he wants credit for the vaccine
he's going to say a lot of dumb stuff
about it right now and i think i think i
think desantis looks a hell of a lot
better in that particular argument
and and desantis did it and and trump
talked about he like his first instinct
was right and
and you know when they first said oh
let's shut down the economy trump's like
we can't do that but then then the
bureaucrats convinced him yeah two weeks
to sell the spread that's how it started
with the trump administration people
don't get that do you think donald trump
would rather solve like heal everybody
of covid but no one knew it was him
forever no one and i hadn't got the
credit or have people suffer for another
year and then slowly come out of it and
then he gets the credit
it's all about credit i think it's all
about credit for that psychopath that's
insane yeah well you can't get an
assumption someone agreed with you and
all of a sudden you're like that proves
it like it's a hypothetical he cares
more about what people think than about
getting the job done when it comes to
the vaccine he wants to credit for it i
credit i think that's trump derangement
syndrome i certainly think trump is
egotistical you're right i'm making an
assumption that of what he thought and
that's like yo he wants credit for the
even even joe biden i would imagine if
if someone came to him and said i am the
great fairy joe biden and i will cure
every one of their elements but trump
will get the credit i still think biden
would be like biden's trash too anyway i
know but i'm saying like
this get in front of public safety is
the idea the idea of the cartoon villain
i don't believe
is real for the most part yeah you know
it's like
i'd rather everyone suffer you know i
don't think trump no it's not it's not a
i don't think it's a cartoon and i think
the problem with politics and
politicians
is that they face incentives where the
if they if they get credit for things
they win and if they don't get credit
they lose and and nobody wants to lose
in politics because the whole point is
winning so the very nature
of the process of politics is corrupting
and it's it's based on ego and arrogance
and fatal conceit and and and trump is
sort of a
he he is sort of leans into that
caricature but he's not he's not all
that different than all these guys but
he's a military commander-in-chief at
that point and when the george floyd
riots broke out day two i i said to tim
we gotta get the national guard in there
now and it didn't happen day two day
three still no national guard and then
people started getting shot
and and he didn't want to get called a
fascist trump didn't want people to
think he was a militant fascist so he
didn't send in the national guard he
just let things burn
that's tough
i mean i don't know what the right
answer is the he's
well there's a lot of news that he's
mentally
he cares more about the way people
perceive him thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you